the Melman co-author of the new book
every spire prints the complete history
of Israel Israel's intelligence
community who was le Cohen le Cohen was
an Israeli spy who penetrated the I
excellence of the Syrian government in
the early 60s and he provided Israel
with the best information available what
was so different about his intelligence
activities what made his story so famous
that he befriended the top echelon of
the Syrian government including the
President of Syria he became a friend of
Syrian Air Force pilot and he provided
the information to Israel and it helped
Israel to win the war the six days war
in 67 and later on he was arrested in
ink by the Syrians so his death is dead
how did he do it well he he was of
Egyptian origins he was born in Egypt as
a Jew later on in the early 50s
emigrated to Israel as many Jews do
recruited by the Israeli intelligence by
the military intelligence later owned by
Mossad trained by them received a new
identity from these Israeli handlers as
a Syrian trader and he went to establish
his identity new identity he went to
Argentina which used to have a huge
Syrian community and he befriended the
Syrian community in Argentina got their
trust and from Argentina from Buenos
Aires was sent to Damascus to Syria
operating as a as a legitimate merchant
but actually was an Israeli spy Dan
Reviva co-author of every spy prints
what's the story about the Israeli
intelligence community's ability to
steal and
a mig-21 from Iraq well what they had to
do was convince a pilot to do it in the
mid-60s
the Israelis are very good at cataloging
everything they possibly can about the
chief officers of the armies of the Arab
countries surrounding them it often
includes Air Force pilots so dossiers
are collected by a mom that's Israeli
military intelligence about everything
they can personal lives where they live
looking for points of weakness well they
found a man called muniya red feh
in Iraq and a an Iraqi Air Force pilot
they found out that he wasn't quite
happy about everything among other
things he was disappointed at the time
were unhappy that Iraq was bombing
Kurdish rebels Kurdish minority villages
just like these days it happens as well
well anyway the Israelis approached him
through a woman they sent a female agent
to Baghdad she befriended him and it was
well within the intelligence business
they call a honey trap she lured him to
go abroad to Paris you know come and in
Paris you can have you know all my
charms and he did and he already was
suspicious that maybe she's an
intelligence officer but he was willing
and in Paris she introduced him to
Israelis took him to Israel the deal was
done a million dollars shelter his wife
and children yes he was married also
were smuggled out of Iraq and the red
fuzz live in Israel now new names etc
got his million dollars and more
importantly Israel and the United States
and everyone Israel wanted to share it
with in the West got a look at that MIG
so it's it's quite a feat considered one
of their best achievements what what got
the two of you interested in doing a
book by the way it said the complete
history of israel's intelligence
community we met in London as the
working is working journalists and that
was in 1981 after a couple of years in
1984 we started the writing articles for
British and American newspapers here for
the Washington Post most of our articles
were dealing with the Middle East with
Israeli politics but also with defense
and security and intelligence related
issues
sometime along the way we thought we
have a story to tell we are writing
articles about the Middle East about
intelligent strategic issues let's try
to write a book about a story which
until then I don't think has been told
in to the extent we wanted it to be told
and we decided that we would try to
research for a book about the complete
history of the Israeli intelligent
because until then until this book comes
out other books had been written but
basically they are of glorifying nature
for trading portraying the Israeli
intelligence as Superman not human
beings and we wanted also to convey the
history of Israel and the problems
facing the Middle East through the eyes
of the intelligence community so this
book is not just about the history of
Israel's intelligence but also to a
certain extent the history of the State
of Israel and the history of the Arab
Israeli Palestinian conflict were you
born and raised I was born in Poland but
raised in Israel my parents emigrated to
Israel when I was six years old that was
in 1957 and all my up group upbringing
is in Israel I mean Israeli citizen I
served in the Israeli army I went to it
to it in Israeli University where are
you now I spent the last year at Harvard
as a Nieman Fellow at Harvard University
and I'm going back to Israel to work as
a journalist there by the way when you
go back to Israel you still have
military duty to do every year yes yes
as a reservist up to 30 40 days a year
Dan Raviv where are you from I'm a New
Yorker born in new york raised in New
York City yeah New York City and my
parents moved out to Long Island where
they are
harvard-educated but then moved overseas
got a job with CBS News as a reporter in
Tel Aviv after two years there moved to
London where I've been for the last ten
years with CBS News we hear you mostly
on the radio that's right to us there's
some television work as well mainly
radio work for CBS when did you first
get interested in the intelligence story
mmm in writing about Israeli politics
with Yosi writing some pieces for the
Washington Post and other newspapers and
it was a repeated fact that a lot of the
information came from well from Israeli
leaks from Israeli experts and we were
fascinated as well with how do they do
it how do they collect so much how does
it work but also from time to time came
across obvious flaws I'll be his
problems I covered trials in Britain of
you know Israelis who were smugglers or
even a kidnapping case where the part of
the defense was we were working for the
Mossad that kind of thing and it made
you wonder how much truth there is in
that and again we all go to the book
store the library I got a book called
the Mossad or whatever and it they can
be wonderful books but it's just
adventure stories that no one's looked
at it seriously that's what we decided
to do so no apologies are calling it the
complete history we certainly did our
best
is 1973 and the surprise of the egyptian
syrian invasion the biggest mistake the
intelligence community's ever made yes
in terms of its impact on on Israel that
was the biggest mistake and it was a
costly one
molded then 2,000 Israeli soldiers were
killed in the 73 war but in terms of the
most embarrassing incident I think that
the failure in 1973 in July 1973 to
assassinate the right person Israel was
after the leader of a Palestinian group
Black September was responsible for the
massacring of Israeli athletes year
earlier at the Olympics and Israel as
Israeli intelligence as ordered by the
prime minister then Golda Meir was after
him and after his associate 12 12 of
them
where were assassinated by these really
intelligence by a hit team selected by
the Mossad and mistakenly in July 73 in
a small town called Lillehammer in
Norway the Israeli hit team killed the
wrong person a poor Moroccan waiter that
was the and they were in some some of
these really agents were arrested by the
Norwegian police that was the colossal
mistake the most embarrassing mistake of
the Israeli intelligence other mistakes
well the 1980s is really the troubled
period not trying to dwell on them but
finding an important pattern that
occurred as political control became
less effective so the invasion of
Lebanon in 1982 a decision made of
course by Prime Minister Bagan and his
then defense minister Ariel Sharon's ax
to go until I've been on clear out the
PLO but based on faulty intelligence the
Mossad believe that it formed a
wonderful partnership with the
Christians of Lebanon that they would
fight alongside the Israelis and it
didn't happen that way and Israel really
paid the price for that Israel's
involvement in Iran gate Israelis told
by their Prime Minister to take part in
the effort to sell arms to Iran do the
Americans a favor it'll do us a favor
again very muddled thinking in the
background and we found the Mossad
wasn't involved in it had tried to stop
it but fail to so bureaucratic wrangling
led to that a nuclear worker Mordechai
Vanunu worked in the Dimona nuclear
reactor when abroad sold many of the
nuclear secrets and the domestic
security people Shin Bet that's the
equivalent of the FBI shouldn't have let
him leave the country with his
photographs of the reactor in the end by
the way the Mossad had to save the day
sent a female agent if this sounds
familiar now to London lured him another
honey trap Vanunu was lured abroad to
Italy and kidnapped chained by the
Mossad in both Israel so in the 80s
again it was a matter of damage control
oh and one last one the Shin Bet again
that sort of FBI agency caught torturing
and killing two Palestinians would
hijacked a bus and then covering up the
fact so in the end the Shin Bet director
had to resign it was
had period the 80s and I even left one
out Jonathan Pollard here in Washington
the American civilian analysts of the
Navy who was who was caught spying for
the Israelis and that's been terrible
embarrassment largely because he was an
American Jew and we say in the book that
the Mossad should have learned ages ago
not to hire is to do that this picture
on the screen is that the picture of the
Palestinian you were talking about yes
on one of the two Palestinian bus
hijackers caught by those are two Shin
Bet agents leading him away their faces
masked at the demand of the Israeli
censor he's being led away he's clearly
alive but later the official report said
all the bus hijackers were caught dead
because someone in the Israeli press had
the guts to print that photo the story
came out that they had captured them and
killed them now maybe if it had been
handled
you know Allah Watergate with an
immediate apology by the authorities
they would have gotten away with it but
they kept denying and covering up here's
a picture of Mordechai Vanunu that's
right that he's in jail right now in
Israel yes so being 18 years in jail for
selling those nuclear secrets he went
abroad he said he was serving you know
the cause of man in effect that the
world should know that Israel has a
nuclear weapon but well I thought maybe
the judges actually listened to his
reasoning because if you will he only
got 18 years I know I'm not pronounce
this right Lacan yes that's right yes
that's the science liaison Bureau or the
Israelis called it calm which protected
the nuclear secrets we reveal it that
was it's real foremost function but then
ended up hiring Pollard the American
here in the US who spied for Israel how
did you and and find out about Lacan
when was the first time it was ever
publicly mentioned over the Pollard
affair until not 1985 when Jonathan
Pollard was arrested here in Washington
no one knew about the existence of such
a secret organization not even in the
Israeli intelligence community it was
the most sacred secret of these really
intelligence which is secret
generally speaking and when Jonathan
Pollard was arrested and Israel had to
apologize for the US government it was
revealed that he was run recruited in
Helmand by lakum dslbd science liaison
bureau and many eyebrows were raised in
Israel come we've never heard of what's
that genuine agency or it was because it
was disbanded right away to please the
Americans prime minister Shimon Peres
disbanded Lacan who does the same job
that lucam used to do now other people
in the defense ministry that's main job
again protecting the nuclear program and
also acquiring scientific and
technological information from around
the world and there's no question the
Israelis still have to do that we ask
you about this book can you buy this
book in Israel today sure it came out in
Hebrew in Israel and quite modestly it
is a best-seller in Israel as well how
much of what you tried to put in here
was kept out by the censors very little
to be frank I think we'd have to admit
it is very little the chapters that
Yossi wrote which in effect came out of
Israel went through the military censor
and there was some haggling and there
always is that it's it's fascinating
system of censorship you can go to the
sensor and complain why you wanted to
take out that paragraph and deal but I
had to submit my chapters do these
really silly because I mean these really
citizen he subject to those laws but you
also have to admit that you know enough
about the system let a little bit your
sense of yourself for instance we know
that there's no point you can't name the
different director of the Mossad why try
what's the point so we didn't why why
won't they name matter of fact you it's
one of the interesting things in the
front of the book here and another James
can get a tight shot of it you list
people who have run the different agent
agencies and and right there near the
one that's I can't see the date was in
1987 1989 just last year the new
director of the Mossad took over and in
parentheses we say disclosure forbidden
by Israeli law what would have been the
point I'll be frank we could have had
his
and it was the point that's not the
point of it now I might land in a J yeah
with Monsieur C terribly now under this
section here the commanders of military
intelligence am on you see a name twice
there that's now fairly famous I am
Herzog who is he and what did he do is
now the president of the State of Israel
and he came from intelligence background
he was he was trained by the British
during the Second World War as an
intelligence officer operated in Europe
after the war immigrated to Israel
joined Israeli army in 1948 and a year
later became a the second director of
Israel's military intelligence of a man
then he was assigned to Washington to
work as the military attache here at the
Israeli embassy in 1954 he returned to
Israel we joined the army stayed in the
army and in 1958 once again was recalled
to become the chief the commander of the
military intelligence later among
brilliant military analysts got into
politics
that's not forget in the United States
we have President Bush was a CIA
director it's not quite the same thing
but of course it's a it's a test of a
man's metal of his patriotism very much
trusted did a great job in military
intelligence so people would trust me as
a wonderful reputation Prime Minister
Shamir also an intelligence background
in his case not military intelligence
the Mossad the foreign espionage arm the
most famous of the agencies if you will
but Shamir won't tell you exactly what
he did
he worked in Paris as operations chief
for Europe for a decade from 1955 to 65
and
got his experience of the world went to
lots of countries within some Arab
countries undercover I read somewhere
and it was a Shimon Perez who's to fly
back and forth and meet with him in
Paris not with him Paris at that time
when Samir was in Paris working for the
Mossad Paris was in charge of he was the
director general it was director general
of the Defense Ministry and he was
cooler and Paris was conducting his own
mini foreign policy cementing the
relations between Israel and France in
the 50s until the 60s France was the
major Alliance supported of the State of
Israel only in the mid 60s this role was
taking over by United States but I don't
think that Paris at that time met with
Samir that was that if they did they
broke in an important internal
intelligence role that's the rule of
compartmentalization or
departmentalization it means that you
should not know the names of your agents
only the others are doing and do your
own thing so to speak simply but all
these years later and it's fascinating
in Israel it is something to be proud of
because Paris now in his campaign
appearances when he when he speaks you
know for the Labour Party will always
point that out that oh I was involved in
clandestine business as well I helped
make sure that Israel has a certain
something in Dimona obviously referring
to the nuclear reactor or I made sure
that we were friendly with France which
meant a lot people are proud of
clandestine experience whereas perhaps
in America people would be ashamed and
and it was France who gave Israel in
1956 1957 it's its first and only
nuclear reactor or it's big meaningful
one there was a little research once yes
yes and so the view we a vital so Paris
has something to be proud of but
fascinatingly he can't reveal it all
either we've been jumping all around
here let's go back to the beginning and
get the basics on the table how many
people in Israel are involved in Intel
activities well it's it's a it's a state
secret nobody would tell you exactly but
we believe that there are more than
10,000 people involved directly employed
directly by the intent by the various
branches of the Israeli intelligence
mainly the military intelligence one has
to remember that the military
intelligence a man is the largest and
the most important intelligence
organization in Israel
before the Mossad before you get to that
I want to show the audience that how
these different organizations are
spelled and explain them each because
your three major intelligence gathering
organizations in Israel you start with
the Mossad what is it Mossad means
Institute by the way and this is an
Institute for intelligence and Special
Operations so the Mossad is the foreign
espionage arm compared it to the CIA
all right go down here to the next one
is Amnon right military intelligence
it's a Hebrew acronym so it is the
intelligence arm of the Armed Forces as
Yossi was saying it in fact is the
largest and most important and then it
says Shin Bet to Hebrew letters initials
for security services that's the
domestic agency the equivalent of the
FBI which one of the three is the most
important it would be I'm on military
intelligence nothing is more important
than your watching your Arab neighbors
for actual movements of troops how many
tanks they have where the aircraft all
these other missions that we described
you're fascinating and even getting you
know thousands of Jews into the country
is vital but war having a sign that war
is coming that's the key and that's a
mantra which is the second most
important the Mossad the problem with
their with the with a man with the
military intelligence is that it lives
in the shadow of the flamboyant Mossad
ah it can be compared to this to the
same problem which is facing United
States National Security Agency NSA it
is the largest the most important agency
in the intelligence community yet the
most in the most famous one which gets
media attention is the CIA
the same is in Israel the Mossad has
become sort of a epitomizing the Israeli
intelligence but the most important
agency is military intelligence Mossad
comes second and then you have a Shin
Bet the Israeli equivalent to the FBI in
charge of fighting terrorism
counterterrorism subversion trying to
foil plots against the State of Israel
political plots and others you tell the
story about how you try to find out what
the what they call the Mossad when they
deal with publicly that was a reasonable
question but the trouble is you can't
pick up the phone book there's no
Langley and in Israel and you can look
up CIA or in our case said the Mossad we
thought we should ask what shall we call
it in English she can translate the
Hebrew words as I said Mossad as
Institute but when they write a letter
to their friends in the CIA or the
British intelligence what do they call
themselves it took a while it was a
matter of asking the prime minister
spokesman the best you could do because
officially the Mossad is under the Prime
Minister's office and I think he sort of
wondered why you want to know and all
that's we explained and he came up with
the Israeli Secret Intelligence Service
if it were to have initials it would be
is is simple words like that
interestingly enough kind of a British
model the British don't really like the
names mi5 and mi6 for their foreign
service they prefer sis Secret
Intelligence Service what was the
toughest bit of information to gather
for this book I think about the extend
the involvement of the Israeli
intelligence in in a topic which is very
unusual for intelligence and this is
immigration that's probably even more
sensitive than dealing with Arab
military capabilities since Israel
perceived itself not just as a state of
the Israelis and for this release but
also state for the Jews whenever
wherever they are so the Israeli
intelligence is becoming the Jewish
intelligence
with two specific missions one to
protect Jewish communities which are in
peril mainly in Arab countries Jewish
communities that are persecuted by the
local authorities and secondly to bring
those Jews from the countries that they
are not allowed to immigrate to bring
him over to Israel recently the Israeli
intelligence were was trying and is
still trying to bring over European Jews
from Ethiopia what was known as
Operation Moses so that I think was even
more it was tougher than talking
researching for Mossad or for a man and
there is a special unit dealing with
Jewish immigration who first of all how
do you become a member of one of these
intelligence gathering organization and
who cannot be a member
hmm well a lot of questions hard to say
they ought to be open-minded and they
might be but most of the agents are
operatives that they recruit are from
elite combat units people usually men in
the Israeli Armed Forces who prove their
their courage and their their
intelligence their their their smarts in
these units occasionally we even spotted
a newspaper ad which appeared to be from
the intelligence community asking for
people with military experience and
languages foreign passport preferred for
interesting work abroad it sounded like
it was probably for the Mossad so maybe
they're having a little bit of trouble
recruiting which we indeed it heard so
personal recommendations or we could be
through academic institutions the army
still is the key which which of course
makes it hard for women by the way
because you don't have women in combat
units you have to be Jewish
well no it's actually not even in the
Israeli army not not everyone is Jewish
it's difficult to be an Arab Muslim and
be in the Israeli army but they have
volunteers as well
there have been Druze certainly know
that minority that's in several
countries of the Middle East including
Israel Circassian
Moslems it's a particulars l'm some of
whom have been wonderfully patriotic to
Israel that's a matter of volunteering
as I say and there are volunteers during
a recent American involvement in Panama
you know at least in this network there
are a tremendous number of calls about
an Israeli Mossad agent with the name of
Harare Mike Harare Frollo the dark glass
fella with the dark glasses right here
this is mr. Noriega whatever happened to
Mike Harare and how did he get to be
this man's intelligence assistant my
kirari
na was an intelligence officer for many
many years he worked for the Shin Bet
for the domestic security service in the
early 50s later on he joined Mossad
foreign arm of the Israeli intelligence
he became an operational officer for the
Mossad in 1972 he was selected by the
head of the Mossad a deadtime general
Samael to lead the hit team which was
after Palestinian terrorists involved in
the in the meaning a massacre of of the
Olympics after the failure of 1973 in
Norway my kirari was not was not was not
asked any questions the failure was
swept under the carpet and the
intelligence community tried to avoid
the embarrassment by by ignoring her
what happened without establishing
Inquirer Inquiry committees to
investigate what really happened what
went wrong and even maybe as a as a
prize as an award he was given a station
assignment to to be station chief in
Central America in Mexico and for six or
five years he worked Mossad for the
Israeli intelligence in Mexico City in
charge of Israeli activities Mossad
intelligence activities in Central
America
that's how he befriended : del Noriega
now in 1980 he retired he left the
service he left the Mossad started
started working as an independent
legitimate businessman as an insurance
broker in Israel he wasn't so successful
and he realized that actually what he
knows is his old craft the intelligence
craft and he went abroad and started
working for colonial Noriega and become
his right-hand man on the day of the
American invasion he got out somehow
that's a very interesting and good
question yeah how like we think the
Americans could have caught him if
they'd really wanted to perhaps you'll
recall there were rumors on the very day
and the next day that they had caught
the Israeli former Mossad man who'd been
Ortega's right-hand man
but they didn't seem to have caught him
because he turned up in Israel and gave
a TV interview the first in his life and
what she said why is everyone picking on
me I was doing work in Central America
have a nice fellow I got my own company
here leave me alone
if you keep saying these things about me
you're putting my life in danger very
first interview in his life at the
beginning of this year January of this
year anyway in Panama I can't say that
we yet had the full explanation but
we've concluded that it's more likely
that Harare like many Israeli
intelligence operatives into this case a
former one knew who's the winning side
he could see Noriega was on his way down
the Americans soon to come in he
probably more or less jumped sides
probably gave the Americans some
information probably was allowed to slip
out just beautifully easily got back to
Israel are there others who used to be
Mossad Shin Bet Aman were now
mercenaries around the world well this
is one of the major concerns of this
book we have a special chapter called
business at all cost are a chapter which
is dealing with the phenomena that many
Israeli veterans of the
intelligence community of the Armed
Forces are looking for new jobs as
consultants as trainers and some of them
are landing up with the most brutal
regimes in the world training drug
dealers in Colombia assisting dictators
in Africa working with the brutal
regimes in Central America and we
believe that the Israeli government must
tighten its control over its citizens
most of them are not anymore in service
they don't work for the government they
don't represent the agencies there are
privateers we call them formers former
intelligence officers former military
officers they believe that they served
Israeli interests we think that they
give is well a bad name Israelis have to
learn how to cut them off and/or employ
them or make it clear who they are and
who they aren't and it has just ruined
Israel's name in many places is it hard
to stay objective you've been on this
story what 10 years 12 years in my case
yeah I got to Tel Aviv in 78 maybe I
consider myself a professional fence
sitter and I don't find it terribly hard
first in Israeli politics between the
Labour Party and the right-wing Likud I
listen to both there's a lot of sense in
what they both say and a lot of problems
and what they both say and then you get
the arab-israeli dispute so now I think
I'm a fence sitter and that especially
for this project it was important not to
bring a political bias to it because so
many people have great stories to tell
and if you just fit them together
carefully almost if I dare say it like
an intelligence operative would do its
boring work usually lots of little
scraps of information we felt like we
were pasting them together and making
sense out of it and then when we could
run it by someone bring it and say is
this the way it happened and if it made
sense great it was a matter of politics
we try to avoid political judgments we
are professional journalists and this
book is not about politics it's about
the Israeli intelligence
and we have been trying to be fair and
to judge it
each incidence on the merit of it
without any political bias let me deal
with something that we get from our
audience all the time you're an Israeli
citizen and people that live in Israel
become very much involved in the fight
to survive how do you then as a
journalist and Israeli citizen to you
know separate yourself from the need to
survive I don't see any contradiction
between me as an Israeli patriot and I'm
not ashamed to declare her that I am an
Israeli Patriot I do believe that Israel
has the right to exist and that there is
a play there must be a place for the
Jews and yet I can be an objective
journalist and that's what I have been
doing since I I left my military service
I served three years in these really are
me like any other Israeli went to
university and since then for 14 years
I've been working as a journalist
establishing myself as a professional
professional journalist and there is no
contradiction as I don't see any
contradiction between a fight for
survival and democracy Israel is doing
both is fighting for its survival
sometimes rightly sometimes with wrong
policies but yet trying to maintain
democratic values and maybe it's a
unique case in in the modern world
intelligent service in Israel you write
about the last several years has the
morale gone down and has the capability
gone down well any intelligence
fraternity is a reflection of its
society and Israel has had its problems
some some might call it the problems of
middle age but when I've said that
before I've been criticised by saying
middle age I mean it's going to die in
30 years I don't really mean that but as
the country became about 40 years old it
faced a new set of challenges a brain
drain this affects the intelligence
community some of the best and brightest
people leaving the country
Oh questions about the values of society
ones
charming small socialist country that
you felt sorry for surrounded by a sea
of Arabs and now the world doesn't feel
sorry for you and all Israelis have to
contend with that including Israel's
spies they don't have the natural
sympathy they had before in various
countries where they wanted to operate
in the past and Scandinavia the case
earlier that we said the hit team that
got arrested the Norwegians did catch
some but went easy on them let them go
not sure that goes so easy on Israelis
these days so there's that problem
recruiting not so much sympathy in the
world not quite as much sympathy at home
either because of the string of failures
in the 80s not all Israelis feel that
comfortable with their secret defenders
anymore so they've got a lot of
challenges now some hopes in the last
two years Israel has launched two
satellites experimental satellites both
of them comecomecome incense burned up
in the atmosphere
there will be more and the satellites in
the future will no doubt be spy in the
sky kind of satellites that will be a
great boost especially to military
intelligence they will feel they can now
see the enemy without relying on the US
for satellite photos that's an example
really the technological edge the
Israelis would like to emphasize and
there are some other examples our
Israeli society and its intelligence as
reflecting the spirit of the society is
trying to reform itself the Israelis
were surprised thirty thirty months ago
by the Palestinian uprising the
Palestinian people suddenly after 20
years of Israeli occupation said enough
is enough and are still involved in a
struggle in civilian disobedience
sometimes getting sore and very violent
and the intelligence was so the
intelligence community was surprised
like the rest of the society and the
Israeli government they didn't believe
that the Palestinians they would would
be able to do it they didn't see the
Palestinians as as a political entity as
people with national aspirations and yet
a year later a year and a half ago it
was the Israeli military intelligence
in charge of providing the government
with the National the annual National
Intelligence Estimate
which acknowledged that the Palestinian
people are led by the PLO whether Israel
like it or not it's a fact of life and
Israel has to accommodate itself with
that political factor now that was the
military intelligence the prime minister
mr. schmear didn't like the idea and he
still doesn't like it but the
intelligence had enough had enough
courage to tell the government this is a
fact of life
you might like it you might not like it
but our job our duty is to tell you the
truth that might be an encouraging sign
because in the past you know with the
prevailing spirit of Israeli politics
intelligence agencies were just going
along going along with the old concept
for instance therefore not seeing the
1973 war coming not seeing the
Palestinian uprising coming maybe
they're getting a little more courage
back now you're right that they got
caught in 73 because they got cocky
after 67 where do you see it today can
they can 73 happen again in 1990 not
really I don't think they have a concept
that the Arabs would never attack yeah
the Israelis are far more cautious now I
don't think they're cocky in fact what
you see this year are exercises by
senior Israeli military officers
including the head of military
intelligence who does talk to the press
the other agency Chiefs are secretive
but military intelligence does I think
he's trying to cheer up the people there
have been a series of press conferences
in Israel in which they explain though
not with full details that Israel can
defend itself against chemical attack or
warheads that might be launched from
Syria or especially Iraq they don't give
the full information but it's almost too
you know keep the people's spirit up is
there a nuclear capability in Israel the
official policy of Israel is that they
never the government net is never
admitted that Israel has nuclear
capabilities nuclear weapons the
official line is the government line is
Israel will not be the first country in
the Middle East to introduce new
new weapons yet it is world widely
assumed that Israel does have nuclear
capabilities and I think that my chapter
baby
no I think the Arabs know it I mean the
especially after Mordechai Vanunu who
worked at the intelligent the nuclear
installations in Dimona went abroad and
told this story sold this story for a
British newspaper by the way where is
Damona located in the south of Israel
and I gave desert and the caution you
saw me express a moment ago was just
basically that it is a taboo topic in
Israel it's generally not for Israelis
to discuss its foreign analysts it's the
CIA for instance who have a keen
interest in Israel's nuclear program
we've been able to establish what they
could and much of the data that I was
able to obtain on that subject came from
foreigners because the signs are there
shipments of certain technology certain
developments that are occurring and I
don't think the Israelis really want you
to think they don't have the nuclear
bomb in other words they want you to
think they do because that has a
deterrence effect the Iraqis are much
less likely to start a war if they think
that they'd immediately be destroyed by
a nuclear bomb and that deterrence well
it actually seems to work you write
about Saddam Hussein before I ask you
the question about him when did you win
was this book when when you put it to
bed what was the date the end of January
this year and you indicated here that
Saddam Hussein of Iraq is trying to
build up the largest force in that part
of the world and become the leader
militarily and we've just experienced an
example of it that surprise you at all
what he did with Kuwait and the oil no
no I'm not surprised and he might have a
few few more surprises in his pocket can
the Israelis handle a million people
under arms in Iran it's it's a tough
question and these really intelligence
these really armed forces are very much
concerned about the size of the Iraqi
army in even more than that about its
quality
Iraq was involved in the last decade in
a bloody war with Iran for ten years in
iraqi soldiers iraqi tank commanders
Iraqi pilots acquired a lot of
experience plus that Iraq has now very
sophisticated delivery capabilities
missiles missiles which can eat Tel Aviv
and Israel is very much concerned about
it just recently the Director General or
number two in the Israeli Defense
Ministry general every a former
commander of the Israeli Air Force said
that he believes that Israel is not
prepared psychologically and otherwise
for the possibility that for the first
time the next war in the Middle East if
there is a war and hopefully I hope that
the world would not occur Israeli towns
would be might be exposed for the first
time in the history of Israel for Arab
attacks missile missiles bombs maybe air
raids all previous wars were fought on
Arab lands in the front and Israeli
citizens civilians were not harmed ya
ask you about money again if you were
sitting seated right at this desk and we
were taking telephone calls by now the
calls would come in saying the United
States gives an extraordinary amount of
money every year to Israel and you'd
hear figures all the way from 3.2
billion up to 10 billion depending on
how you didn't calculate it I want to
ask Dan Raviv how much money every year
does the US taxpayer give to Israel I
think basically it's the published grant
and loans and I know most of the loans
end up being excused of 3.8 billion
dollars is where it stands that's what
the Israelis are working on to keep it
at the very least 23.8 they no longer
expect increases is that including the
housing money for the immigrants
probably not but those are supposed to
be loan
aren't they and it's not going to exceed
that by much even if it touches four
billion because of some special
allocations because of special needs
there's not a lot of hidden money there
somewhere coming in with in various ways
no I really don't think that there is
you can talk about the expense but I
don't think it would be right to of the
sixth fleet the US fleet in the
Mediterranean visiting - Harbor but
that's very much in the US interest they
really do want to visit the harbor there
they really do want to preposition
weapons medical supplies in Israel
rather secretive don't know the full
details of that but that's not really
for the sake of Israel that's the US
that wants a little pre positioning in
Israel I guess what I'm trying to say is
and I hear it all the time when I go to
Israel they don't want to tell me
everything but they're always trying to
assure an American visitor such as
myself that it's worth it the US you
guys are getting the value you are did
anybody come to you you'll see either
one of you is matter-of-fact and say
don't write this book no no did anybody
come to you and say we understand you're
writing this book and we'd appreciate
you not writing about say that if your
bomb situation well as Dan mentioned
earlier being in Israeli working in
Israel I know how these really
censorship and now the defense
establishment is working so there there
were certain elements which I believed
it would endanger life so I decided I
wouldn't write about them like naming
Mossad agents working in Arab countries
I wouldn't do it it's really endangering
their life and it's it's not necessarily
to do it you know that for a fact you
know we are they I there were some well
I I don't know all of them and that's
the way it should be but at least I can
think of one case when I self-censored
myself when it when it comes to that
kind of information
are there any Arab intelligence agents
that have ever been caught inside Israel
oh yes but most of the attempts compared
with the sophisticated Israeli efforts
to set up the laboratory
stories and plant people in Syria as we
discussed and also in Egypt the Arab
efforts are kind of elementary on the
other hand of course those that are
truly successful you never hear about
but the people who were caught not too
impressive not that many I think we only
have about five cases or so someone who
came from Egypt took another identity
moved there as a you know as a Jew who
was moving there the concern by the
Israelis is really much more it has been
with Soviet bloc penetration well now
there's not a Soviet bloc but has been
with with that concern they've been on
the lookout for communist country
penetration always in the belief and it
was a valid one that the Soviet Union
would pass along almost everything had
learned to Syria or it sometimes to
Egypt in other words to Israel's enemies
so they're on the lookout for Soviet
agents they still are we have 10,000 and
more Soviet Jews moving to Israel every
month now that Gorbachev has opened the
gates it's a certain thing that there
are spies KGB spies among them plant
what's the closest that any Israeli
intelligence as some a Mossad agent has
gotten to Yasser Arafat well is yes yes
Arafat was for several years at least in
the early 60s and maybe even early 70s
top on the Israeli agenda he the Israeli
intelligence wanted to get him
assassinated assassinate him and I think
even we talked about it in our book even
in during the war in Lebanon car car
bombs exploded near his headquarters
aerial bombing seemed to take place only
for the reason that he was reported to
be in that apartment they missed him and
he's a he's a great survival and he
survived endless attempts on his on his
life not just by Israeli agents also he
has a lot of Arab enemies Palestinian
extremists such as Abu Nidal Syrian
agents on the other hand there is a
question maybe it's a more of
philosophical nature which has been
discussed by the Israeli intelligence
what good would it do if we kill the
head of a terrorist organization
sometimes maybe it's better to to let
him live since we can deal with the
devil we know rather than with the
uncertainties of a replacement and I
think that the approach that is used by
these real intelligence is that when you
are dealing with small tiny terrorist
organizations organizations which are
depended heavily on the leader it's like
small gangs then maybe if you kill the
leader you destroy the organization but
when it comes to larger groups like the
one that is led by Yasser Arafat it
won't do any good by killing the leader
very very much this picture it's the
other hand there always is another hand
in this business it's a picture of a
villa in Tunisia near the capital Tunis
where a mossad team with special Israeli
commandos landed from the sea just over
two years ago and killed Abu jihad the
number two man in the PLO you see that's
the on the other hand it wouldn't do any
good to kill Yasser Arafat so the
thinking goes but to remind the PLO of
who's really in charge of the long reach
of the Mossad in April 88 one of the men
who was organizing the Palestinian
uprising was killed at his home in that
villa in Tunisia Dhaka monie we've heard
this name recently there's been another
book out on Pan Am 103 here's a picture
it's a strange-looking picture though
Yossi explained why it doesn't look
normal because this picture was taken by
a hidden camera photographed of delq
emoni which y'see right yes this one
this is Dell Kamali
the notorious now Kamali it was taken by
West German agents trade shadowing him
when he was in Germany planning his
attack on Pan Am
it belongs in this book because the
Germans were onto the so-called Delta
mony cell part of the PFLP general
Palestinian terrorist group based in
Syria they were onto him thanks to his
Raley tips the Israelis were also
watching the cell wondering what they
were up to the conclusion reached they
wanted to blow up an aircraft but they
thought another aircraft a flight from
Spain to Israel was the target so they
felt very pleased when the terror cell
or most of the members were arrested in
October of 88 and that flight was safe
but two months later the Germans had
allowed most of the alleged terrorists
out and two months later Pan Am 103 blew
up general question we got out of time
what have we not covered in here that
you think the audience that will read
this book will find fascinating what
what elements of the book I was
surprised to find out what I would call
the humanitarian side of the Israeli
intelligence and that's what maybe makes
this really intelligence so unique and
so special there is a special unit in
Israel in charge of emigration try to
imagine the CIA or British mi6 are
involved in that kind of of work since
Israel is the state of the Jewish people
so is the Israeli intelligence the
Jewish intelligence and is trying to
bring over Jews from countries like Iran
from some Arab countries which don't
allow them to immigrate and this is a
fascinating story it's a very heroic
story Israeli agents are ready to go to
the most obscure places and danger
places in the world to bring over their
Jewish brethren and what about the
history a lot of the history of the
Mossad and Amman and all that stuff what
did you find in the history of the
organizations that you found
particularly interesting lessons that
were learned and should have been
learned in the early years we start in
1948 with the birth of the state we
haven't discussed the title every spy of
prints the the notion that God told
Moses to choose the first spies thirty
two centuries ago to go into the Land of
Israel choose them from every tribe
every one of them a prince they were
supposed to be the elite and the history
in the upper left rule then she Louis
the 1st Prince of
intelligence what a dedicated man mr.
intelligence the founder of the Mossad
Reuven Sheela almost unknown and there
in the upper right if it's in the
picture as well as isser Harel now he is
no because he's written books on the
subject he was the head of Israeli
intelligence va mieux
or Emperor of these really great emperor
and indeed made it into an empire and
there in the lower level of Egor one of
the founders of Israeli intelligence
interested in what Yossi just mentioned
you he was in charge of debt unit called
reveal for the first time in our book
liaison Bureau in charge of bringing
over Jews from the Soviet Union in
eastern bloc countries in all that the
book maybe this is the fair question
who's your favorite intelligence
operative over the years that you wrote
about how fascinating it's hard to say
yeah I know I guess as a professional
fence-sitter I don't have abiding
affection necessarily you get you admire
le Cohen for his ability to penetrate
Syria but then he went too far kept
transmitting on the Morse code key got
caught got hanging you think that was
dumb you admire Wolfgang Lots for doing
it in Egypt and maybe admire him more
because he got away with it the
champagne spine that's what he called
himself they remember him well they
remember him at Mossad headquarters
especially because of his expense
accounts lots of champagne but lots of
Egyptian officials loved him who do you
remember I think the true Vinci Lua was
a very interesting person he tried to
maybe imitate to build the Israeli
intelligence from scratches
build it to model it on the British
example to bring British spy espionage
craft into the Israeli society and he
will he was laying down all the
fundamental details which later on
became became so obvious so identified
with the Israeli intelligence and the
imagination to even know that Israel
should negotiate with Arabs last
question we are out of time this book is
dedicated to Dorie Jonathan and Emma who
are they my wife my two kids and two
Billy and your Tom my wife and my kid
the name of the book is every spy a
prince the complete history of Israel's
intelligence community our two guests
have been dan Raviv and Yossi Melman
thank you gentlemen both for joining us
and to our audience have a good day